non è vero non è vero
oddio faccio amo amo uscite dalle maglie
ma come chiesto riuscire rischio che
sono contenta che non va bene ma
comunque lo saprò mai perché tra due ori
e tradurre ad appuntamenti non è che la
marmitta ben due ore
[Musica]
così troppo aggressiva ma no la
camicetta fa troppo brava ragazza quando
vado a posto e paillettes dice mi
facessi di rom
alla fine la sua intera bionda quindi è
difficile bionda ragazza non ce la
faccio non ce la faccio impazienti
aiutatemi dove è stata una soluzione
l'avete sentito anche voi
nessuna scusa il suo messaggino si
guarda mi dispiace ma il gatto mi pare
di arresto a ritirare o facile no
amo oggi esco con marco te lo giuro
iscritto adesso ovvio che accettato di
pare che fra due ore sia e voglio anzi
arssa tv ti lascio voglio rilassarmi non
ci sentiamo dopo
[Musica]
amo stai tranquilla lo so che mancano
dieci minuti ma non devo mica prepararmi
e fare chissà che mi metterò una maglia
in jeans cioè questi giorni vecchi tisi
proprio alla fine se devo piacergli
charito piacere per quella che sono
no questo non lo so quindi spero da qui
a tutta la prima parte che la chiesa
sicuro quindi vada tranquilla speriamo e
qui questo non lo so questo non lo so
questa non so ma dovrebbe non chiederla
ma ecco amo amo sono io allora sta per
iniziare mi raccomando hai tutto società
il tutto sotto mano mi raccomando veloce
ramo perché non mi delle sei mesi se
mischia ma alla fine se viviamo la fine
io non mi laureerò mai chiusi sino alle
8 da quella brava che mai ricordato ti
senti bene tu senti bene il suo volume
mi senti ok roxy salve
[Musica]
adesso ci siamo
allora
appunto socializzazione è diventata
nella marina guardi che sono qui a
laveno si prof
scusi è che tutto questo studio mi ha
fatto venire un po di fame che senso
mancano solo tre settimane le vacanze ma
non è possibile ma sembra niente ramazzo
innamorato ma io mi vogliono sono pronte
per la prova costume
quest'area si muove potrei scrivere in
palestra niente mi devo b devo iniziare
assolutamente ad allenare da casa subito
ora
[Musica]
per te questo e altro ma non ce la
faccio
[Musica]
lo sai che chi lavora chi ha però sempre
ma non penso di farcela proprio essere
state mi dispiace sarà per la prossima
scusa tra tre settimane sono in vacanza
adoro ma il tempo è volato
magari questa estate potrei trovare
l'amore della mia vita
nel frattempo mi alleno e meglio
[Musica]
guarda
si scusa
eccola con la mira fini grazie
rigidissimo ma tu sei un personal
trainer
no perché ti vedo cioè bello criticato
cioè se sia quello che ti capita e senti
ma se ci allenassimo insieme dai
liquidatori certo andiamo
oggi ho proprio voglia di cucinare
voglio volete vedere una scelta e
d'altronde scusami se c'è la ricetta
tutti i passaggi
cosa dovrei sbagliare beh queste allora
la facciamo a fine e allora passiamo ai
immagini che li tagliamo grossolanamente
ricordiamo in padella
io sto facendo come si brucia si mette
l'acqua l'acqua puzza un po però magari
il sapore buono ce ne sarà sempre così
sempre così ma iniziamo troppa troppa
troppa fame non vedo l'ora di mangiare
vediamo cosa c'è di buono nova a d'oro
[Musica]
la voglia di cucinare mangiare un
piacere
non posso farlo in maniera easy ancora
meglio ma sono un regalo devono
assolutamente d'armi a una ritoccatina
non si può neanche truccare in pace però
c'è un minimo vado di costa aspettare si
arrivò no vabbè ma mi sono ma mica
ho allora anche questo fatto
magari mi dà una sistematina perché va
bene o di cipria
dai
dario muoviti però dai terra ma se no
non me l'hanno facendo questo ma ti vuoi
muovere ma chi vuoi muove amico oggi è
il tuo giorno fortunato perché perché
vedi con insegna luminosa
quello è il ristorante della mia
migliore amica e tu dirai quindi e
quindi lì davanti c'è il parcheggio
riservato oggi il giorno di chiusura
sono appena passata è libero vai e tutto
tuo ciao a un'ultima cosa non
disturbarmi è una ragazza mentre si
trucca ora che non sono mica tutte
scialle smart come me fai attenzione
lo dico perché c'è una giornata come al
solito devo sempre risolvere tutto io
dov'eravamo rima
[Musica]